Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an American comedy-drama film
called “An American Pickle.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie begins in the year 1919 in a
place called shtetl in Eastern Europe.
Herschel Greenbaum is a struggling Jewish
laborer who works as a ditch digger.
His job is tiresome and makes him little to no
money. Most of the money he earns, he spends on
buying new shovels which break frequently.
Herschel narrates that his life is tough
but that was until he saw the love of his life,
Sarah for the first time. By buying her a golden
fish from the market, he wins her over and the
two become friends. They have a lot in common,
like the fact that both their parents were
murdered by Russian Cossacks. The pair’s greatest
wish is to be able to afford their own gravestone
one day. A few months later, they get married,
hoping for a peaceful life together. However,
their plans are ruined when the Russian Cossacks
attack the village right after the wedding
ceremony. To escape the life of living in fear,
the couple moves to America. They are frequently
called antisemitic slang but Herschel claims
that the Americans treat them way better than
Russians did. He gets a job at a pickle factory
where he earns a nickel for every ten rats he
kills. The couple works hard and finally buys
two graves to be together even after death.
Not long after, Sarah gets pregnant with their
first child. But everything changes when one
day, Herschel falls into a vat of pickles
just as the factory is closed for health reasons.
The vat is covered, and he is stuck inside it for
the next one hundred years. Time passes but no
one comes to look for him. Until two youngsters
enter the factory and open the vat’s lid that
was accidentally knocked out by their drone.
Even after a hundred years of being stuck inside
it, Herschel is alive and well. His story becomes
the talk of the city and a convention is
held to explain how he was able to survive.
The scientists provide a very believable
explanation which the media accepts.
Following that, Herschel is taken to the hospital
for a check-up and is found to be in perfectly
good condition except for his anger issues. On
running a background check, the doctors find out
that all of Herschel’s descendants are dead except
for his great-grandson, Ben. After they contact
him, they find out he lives in Brooklyn and is
more than happy to pick up his great grandfather.
Ben meets Herschel and is surprised to see that
the two look almost identical. When Herschel steps
out of the building for the first time, he is
mesmerized by the skyscrapers and the vehicles.
Everything has changed since he last saw New
York. Ben is excited to be able to show his
great grandfather all the new inventions.
When they reach Ben’s apartment, Herschel is
even more shocked. Used to living in poverty, he
thinks that the place is massive and luxurious.
Ben welcomes him to live there as long as he wants
but Herschel thoughtfully says he doesn’t want to
be a burden on him. Herschel’s excitement only
gets bigger when he gets to drink Seltzer water,
a drink that was reserved for royalties in his
time. Ben makes Alexa play an old song and the two
dance together. After settling down, Herschel asks
Ben what he does for work, assuming that he might
be a doctor or a lawyer. He is visibly confused
when Ben says he is a freelance app developer. Ben
explains that he has been developing an app called
"Boop Bop'', for the past five years and is very
passionate about it. It is a service that checks
companies' ethics when buying their products.
Herschel sees no pictures of the family on the
walls, so he asks Ben about it. Ben shows him a
family photo album which gets Herschel emotional.
He sees Sarah’s picture and finds out that he had
a son. On being asked about his parents, Ben gets
uncomfortable. He says that they passed away in
an accident. The next day, they go to visit the
graves of their family and to Herschel’s horror,
the cemetery is in shambles. Seeing his wife’s
poorly kept tombstone, he can't help but cry.
Some workers are putting up a billboard of Russian
vodka right on top of their graves. This reminds
Herschel of the Cossacks who killed his parents
and loved ones back in Shtetl. An enraged Herschel
asks them to put it down but they do not oblige,
making him assault them. Ben tries to stop him but
gets beaten up instead. This results in both of
them being arrested. Ben spends a large sum of
money and bails them out. That day, Ben goes to a
meeting with an investor who is willing to invest
in his app. But he is devastated to find out that
the investors have dropped him because of his
criminal report. He returns home and blames
Herschel for making his life go downhill.
Herschel doesn’t understand Ben’s ideas and claims
that they should start a pickle business instead.
In a fit of rage, Ben says that Sarah would be
ashamed of him if she were alive. At that moment,
Herschel vows to build a pickle empire and make
his dead relatives proud by cutting down the
billboard. He storms out of the apartment after
calling Ben a dishonor to their family name.
At first, he goes to the grocery store to buy
cucumbers but they are too expensive. While
wandering around, he notices that the bin outside
of the store has packed cucumbers in it. He brings
them with him and in a similar fashion, collects
all the necessary ingredients from dumpsters
around the city. Using a shopping cart, salt, and
rainwater, he is able to finally make the brine
for the pickles. Following that, he puts up
a tiny pickle stand by the side of the road.
He sells his first jar for four dollars to a
couple. Since he hasn’t added any preservatives
and is selling them at a lower price than
the grocery store, the number of customers
increases. He also asks them to bring the jars
back after they are finished, this way the people
believe his business is environment friendly.
His customers start to post him on social media
which grows his business exponentially. Soon, Ben
finds out about Herschel’s local pickle business
that everyone is talking about. While he
struggles to create ideas for his new app,
he is told that Herschel’s business is a
massive hit. This gets him jealous.
One day, he calls the health department and
files a complaint about Herschel using products
found in the trash bins to create his pickles.
This causes his business to shut down and he
is fined $12,000. Herschel is left right where he
started without any resources. Two of his faithful
customers advise him to hire interns since he
wouldn’t have to pay them. Herschel is inspired
by the idea, even though he thinks it is similar
to slavery. He hires a group of interns to brine
and package the pickles. Soon, they use proper
ethical methods to make them and are approved
by the health department. The interns also help
him sell the pickle on a larger scale making the
business quickly go back up. In no time, Herschel
earns enough money to purchase the billboard and
take it down. In the meantime, Ben sees that the
people who were supposed to invest in his app
are now wanting to invest in Herschel’s business.
To proclaim his victory, Herschel brings the
billboard back to Ben’s apartment. He says that he
wants to help Ben because, at the end of the day,
they are family. But Ben is not fond of the idea
and just wants the man to go away. As they chat,
Herschel comments how the Polish men are stupid.
This gives Ben another idea on how he can end the
pickle business; he suggests Herschel create a
Twitter account. That evening, with an intern’s
help, Herschel tweets controversial statements
about women, religion, and homosexuality.
The following day, people swarm before
his shop and protest against his ideas
urging everyone to boycott his pickle business.
His interns also leave his side and join
the protestors. Even after that, Herschel
stays firm in his opinions. As time passes,
he earns support from conservative groups who see
him as an icon of free speech and empowerment. He
even gets selected to appear for a debate with
a college professor on the subject of ethics.
At first, his statements about women, in general,
are seen as bold opinions. But then, a disguised
Ben from the audience, asks him about his thoughts
on Christianity. Herschel proceeds to say that the
Virgin Mary invented Christianity to hide the fact
that she had sexual relations. He calls everyone
who believes in Jesus, an idiot. Because of the
comment, the people who were on his side till now,
chase him down the streets of New York, wanting
to kill him for disrespecting their religion. He
manages to save his life by hiding in an alleyway.
At night, he sees a news report about protests
happening all across America to boycott him once
and for all. Authorities start to dig up his past,
wanting to deport him back to Eastern Europe.
Moreover, because of the outdated filing system
in the storage facility, the paperwork
for Herschel’s arrival cannot be located.
This gives the authorities an excuse to
revoke his citizenship. He is declared
a fugitive illegal alien and the people are
asked to report the police if they see him.
With no way out, Herschel goes to his only family,
Ben for help. Not wanting to return to Shtetl,
he says that he will move to Canada and start a
business there. Ben reluctantly agrees to help
him for the last time. The two drive to Canadian
borders and walk through the woods to illegally
enter the country. On their way, Ben accidentally
cuts his palm, and Herschel tears a piece of his
clothes to bandage the wound. At night, he
hugs his great-grandson to keep him warm.
Although Ben has said vicious things to him,
Herschel considers him family. The next morning,
they finally reach the border but have to hide
when they are almost spotted by border patrol.
While chatting, Ben feels bad for Herschel
and confesses that he was the one who asked
him the question about Christianity because
he wanted to sabotage the pickle business.
Ben hopes that Herschel will forgive him but
he is punched in the face instead. He falls
unconscious and the commotion attracts the border
patrol’s attention. Herschel hides and finds Ben’s
razor and clothes in a bag. He quickly thinks of
a way to escape and disguises himself as Ben.
The officers arrest Ben, thinking he is Herschel
while Herschel, himself is let free because he has
Ben’s ID. Following that, Ben is put on trial but
his case is considered a joke when he pleads that
he is not Herschel. Eventually, he is sent to
Shtetl instead of his great grandfather. He is
alone and cold in a town filled with strangers who
do not speak English. He tries to talk to people,
asking them for a place he can spend the night
in. He ends up in a synagogue and decides to
stay there. Meanwhile, Herschel feels awful for
his great-grandson. He goes to his apartment and
looks through the family photo album. While
reminiscing about the old days, he finds a
drawing that Ben had made of his parents as a kid.
It is only then, that Herschel finds out Boop and
Bop were pet names that Ben gave his parents. He
realizes that Ben had always wanted to honor his
parents and feels terrible that he misjudged him.
Following that, the man decides to go to Shtetl
and bring Ben back home. Meanwhile, in Shtetl,
Ben is called by the people of the synagogue to
perform prayer and pay respect to the dead family
members. He gets emotional during the prayer but
it makes him feel a lot lighter afterward. To
his surprise, Herschel appears in front of him
and apologizes for his actions. He says that Ben
is exactly what he wanted his descendants to be
and claims his parents must be proud
of him. The pair reconcile and go by
a lake that used to be Sarah’s favorite spot.
They discuss starting a pickle business together,
where they can pickle more than just
cucumbers. Ben offers to create a website
for their company through which they can sell
worldwide. The two finally return to Brooklyn
and pay a visit to Sarah’s grave. In the
final scene, they pray together in the
honor of the dead family members.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.